even as the abortion issue has been such
a loser for Dems in the midterm
elections they're doubling down on it
this week on The View those sort of
cackling hens of the liberal
establishment came out and they're
they're Furious because the abortion
issue has not worked to bring the women
over to the Democrat Party they don't
change their views on it they don't have
any introspection they just attack the
women who are voting for Republicans as
cockroaches
I read a poll just yesterday that white
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right
now
okay so do we love it in the hands do we
love democracy or not because just
saying that it's insulting to the voter
people make up decisions on what's right
for their family and the idea that well
you should have a say for everyone
else's but the fact that women are
voting again you had a different view on
abortion not long ago
but that issue is right but then why but
then why is another woman
that white Republican Suburban women
that'll probably win them over don't you
think when when you have voters that
you're trying to court who reject you
and your platform the the way to win
them over is to insult them and call
them cockroaches and idiots right hey
idiot roaches
you got to vote for me dummies you dumb
disgusting people vote for me yeah okay
let's try that one until next Tuesday
please keep that going and it's so
offensive but you hear the you hear this
argument from Democrats all the time and
they apply it to black people and
Hispanics and all the rest they say
you're voting again and they apply to
the working class you're voting against
your own interest
and they're so smug about it it's in
your interest to vote for us Democrats
because we'll give you money and we'll
let you kill your babies
did it ever occur to these women
to these Democrats broadly that maybe
mothers don't consider it in their
interest to kill their own children
did they have they ever considered that
maybe workers don't consider it in their
own interest to vote for a party that is
going to destroy the energy industry
potentially plunge the world into World
War III and cause record high inflation
which disproportionately affects the
poor did they ever consider that it
might not be in the interest of black
people to vote for a party that wants to
get rid of all the cops and and allow
neighborhoods that are already Rife with
crime to become even more criminal and
dangerous did it ever occur to them did
it ever occur to these people that may
be Hispanics in the United States
especially those who came here legally
don't think that it is their interest to
have a completely open border and fled
the country with foreign Nationals just
because they have roughly the same Hue
of skin as that that they do
did it ever no of course not they're
just so freaking smug they are
frequently wrong but they are never in
doubt and they are doubling down and
they are not going to give up their
narrative and it looks like it's going
to absolutely destroy them
on Tuesday hence Governor Bateman's
Governor newsom's prediction
hey Michael I had a question about
pursuing a good career for young people
um it seems to me that my older friends
and my peers have different perspectives
on this this is kind of oversimplifying
it but I would say that the older
generation seem to have a perspective
about work that it's just your
responsibility and you have to do it and
you know yeah chasing your dreams is
okay but ultimately you just have to do
what's going to put food on the table
and the younger Generations seem to have
more of an intense focus on finding your
true passion and what your calling is
and I think there's some crossover but
uh what would be your advice to someone
who's young who's trying to figure out
where they fit in their career because
I'm finding it really difficult to find
what my sweet spot is and it seems like
a lot of employers nowadays want to know
what that is
um and you know I'm obviously very
passionate about being able to put food
on the table but there's also some truth
in that you can probably find a much
easier path to success if you're in work
that you love and work that you're good
at and so I'd just love to hear your
perspective on this thanks so much love
the show
thank you I don't recommend desperately
chasing your dreams I think that's a bad
idea
but I do recommend strategically and
methodically and prudentially pursuing
your dreams
it's it's not just follow your dreams or
settle for some job that you hate that
will give you a steady paycheck
there is another option there too which
is you can apply rigor and reality and
logic and Prudence to the pursuit of
your dreams as well
I have a fake job
in the sense that if you just look at
the hours that I work I I work all the
time I work a lot I am
there are very few hours where I'm not
doing something that somehow relates to
my job for most of the week
but I feel like I am never working
or at least very rarely working because
I love what I do because I have a fake
job because I get to go and speak about
the things that I care about and write
essays and books about the things that I
care about and talk to you guys on the
show and get to have some influence in
politics on things that I want to so and
all of that
fortunately relates to my job I've
worked plenty of other just pay the
bills jobs
and and as I have pursued my dreams I've
gone down bad paths on my dreams and had
to turn around and I've met certain dead
ends and then I've kind of zigzagged and
so there's all of that and now I've
worked different jobs to kind of pay the
bills and keep a roof over my head while
I was doing that
it would be a it would be a mistake to
throw off all of your responsibilities
to just chase some pipe dream that very
likely will not be good for you very
often the things that we think our
dreams are are very are would ultimately
be sort of harmful for us and God
generally has better plans for us than
we have for ourselves because he is
omniscious and Omni benevolent and we
are
fallen and corrupt and have little
pea-sized brains uh so it's it's good
you you ought to have a sense of where
you want to go you ought to have
ambition you ought to really apply some
rigor to that thought
and you want to pursue it and you ought
to do the right thing and you ought to
not compromise morally
and if you can do all that while meeting
your obligations to your family to your
community to your God and if you can do
all of that while meeting your moral
obligations as well and while
you know acting with virtue then I think
that's great
I'm not you know a lot of conservatives
on this question let's say give up your
dreams and just work some job that you
hate that gives you a paycheck I don't
think that's true
I didn't take that advice and I'm glad I
didn't
just like you'll often hear conservative
say you forget about you should never go
to college and if you do go to college
you should never study anything that has
anything to do with culture or
Humanities you should just study
engineering or something I don't think
that's true I didn't follow that advice
and no if you if you have an inclination
toward philosophy or history or
literature or culture and you have any
inclination or aptitude and aptitude for
it at all then yeah you absolutely
should pursue that
but don't just go take out you know half
a million dollars in debt and have no
plan for what you're going to do after
but absolutely you can do that come on
if we're I I don't think the
conservatives are the political party of
kill all of your dreams don't think of
anything higher than just putting a slab
of beef on the table no of course not
that's the what the materialists say
that's what the libs say conservatives
understand that there is much more to
life and that if we want to have a
thriving family and thriving communities
and we want and and we want to pursue
the purpose that God has for us that we
do need to have higher ideals and we do
need to have a broader view of life than
just consuming stuff all right there's
more to get to I've got the regular old
written mailbags I'm going to get to a
few of those in the member block and
then it is fake headline Friday so I
will need your help Ben Davies has given
me
four real headlines one fake headline
he's going to test my ability to
understand our always absurd news cycle
to parse fact from fiction the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]